AS A KID GROWING UP IN THE 70s
, I LOVED SCIENCE FICTION
MOVIES.
MY FAVORITES, PLANETS OF THE
APES.
THE OMEGA MAN, AND OF COURSE
FRIED GREEN TOMATOES.
AS A KID I IMAGINE THE FUTURE I
FRIGHTENING AND WEIRD.
BATTLING ROVING BANDS OF
MARAUDERS, WHO CAN FORGET MAD
MAX AND THE SEQUEL TO ROAD
WARRIOR, RIVETING TALES OF
DYSTOPIAN EARTH.
WHERE SURVIVAL BECOMES A DAILY
CHALLENGE FOR THEM THERE IS KUR
RUSSELL AND ESCAPE FROM NEW YOR
AND LATER LOS ANGELES.
FUNNY HOW THOSE WALLS WORKED.
A VERY FUNNY FILM SOCIETIES
THINKING IN CRIME AND
AMBIVALENCE.
I LOVE THESE MOVIES BECAUSE LIK
JOB A HARD REMAINING EMPLOYED,
ASSUMED IT COULDN'T HAPPEN.
AND LESS A COULD BE CAUSED BY
ONE MAJOR EVENT LIKE A METEOR
STRIKE OR A NUCLEAR WAR OR
HILLARY BECOMING PRESIDENT.
I HAD NO IDEA THAT SOCIETY
THROUGH HITS IN INACTION AND
COWARDICE COULD LET IT HAPPEN T
A BY DAY, SLOWLY, INTO LO AND
BEHOLD THE DYSTOPIA SHOWS UP AT
YOUR FRONT YARD LIKE A NAKED
AMWAY SALESMAN.
BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
THE LOCAL NEWS SAYS SO BUT
THEY'RE IGNORED TO.
IN AMERICA HAS BECOME THE FROG
SITTING IN THAT POT OF SLOW
BOILING WATER HAVING NO IDEA
THAT ENZYME HE WILL BE A FRENCH
GUY GUYS APPETIZER WHICH MEANS
IT IS TIME FOR THINGS DON'T LOO
GOOD.
DID YOU EVER HEAR OF BURGERVILLE
?
IT'S A FAMOUS CHAIN OF BURGER
JOINTS, SURPRISED?
IN PORTLAND, AND I HAD TO CLOSE
ONE OF ITS MOST POPULAR PLACES
DUE TO RISING CRIME,
HOMELESSNESS, AND HUMAN WASTE.
APPARENTLY, THEY'RE CUSTOMERS
PREFER THEIR CHEESEBURGERS
WITHOUT A SIDE OF.
AMAZING, YOUR BUSINESS CLOSES
BECAUSE YOUR LITERALLY TIRED OF
ALL THE.
DENVER SPENDS MORE ON THE
HOMELESS THEN STUDENTS ARE
VETERANS.
NEW YORK TOO.
HAVE YOU BEEN TO NEW YORK LATELY
?
HAVE YOU BEEN TO ANY MAJOR CITY
IT'S LIKE BURNING MAN MINUS THE
GOOD DRUGS GREAT SOME CITY
STREETS LOOK LIKE THE INSIDE OF
CHARLIE SHEEN'S MOUTH.
AND SAN FRANCISCO, A WOMAN LEAN
OUTSIDE A CAR WINDOW EIGHT
BRANDISHING AN AK-47.
I GUESS PELOSI IS HANDLING HER
OWN SECURITY NOW.
IN MINNESOTA A MAN BEHEADED A
WOMAN ON A SEVERE STREET THIS
WEEK A WOMAN SHOT ANOTHER WOMAN
DEAD ON THE BUSY NEW YORK CITY
STREETS BEFORE CASUALLY
RETURNING TO HER WHITE DOUBLE
PARKED SUV.
HOW DID SHE NOT GET A PARKING
TICKET?
I'LL TELL YOU WHY, THE DRIVER
HAD THE HAZARD LIGHTS ON.
TALK ABOUT PRIORITIES.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
GETTING OF PARK IT TICKET ON TO
OF MURDER.
WOMAN KILLS HER HUSBAND IN
INDIANA, CHOPS THEM UP, AND GET
THE KIDS TO HELP DISPOSE OF THE
BODY.
I USED TO COMPLAIN WHEN I WAS
ASKED TO TAKE OUT THE TRASH.
I GUESS IT'S A GOOD WAY TO GET
KIDS TO DO THE CHORES, AT LEAST
YOU TURN TRAGEDY INTO QUALITY
TIME WITH THE KIDS.
IN OTHER NEWS, AN ELDERLY MAN
GETS BRUTALLY BEATEN, I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S LATES
APPROVAL ANOTHER IN A WHEELCHAI
GETS TOSSED AND RANSACKED.
BUT WOULD BE CHOKES HER OUT AND
DROVE HER OFF THE SUBWAY.
STRAY GUNFIRE STRIKES PEOPLE
SITTING ON THE BUS IN QUEENS,
MEN CASUALLY WALK OVER AND SLUG
ELDERLY WOMEN ON THE STREET.
THAT IS TEN MINUTES OF RESEARCH
ON MY PART OF THE PAST WEEK,
JUST TEN MINUTES PER THE SAME
TIME IT TAKES BIDEN TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION OATMEAL OR CREAM O
WHEAT.
MEANWHILE, WHAT DO YOU HEAR FRO
THE MEDIA?
LIPS TURNS OF CLASSIC.
>> IF YOU WATCH A CERTAIN STATE
TV, AND YOU LISTEN TO
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA, YOU WOULD
THINK ENTIRE CITIES ARE JUST
ENTHRALLED INVITES EMPIRES AND
WHATEVER.
WE WENT OUT FOR A GREAT DINNER
IN NEW YORK CITY TONIGHT.
PEOPLE WALKED UP TO US AND SAID
THANK YOU FOR I WATCH YOU EVERY
NIGHT, AND CAN'T BELIEVE THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO DO A
DOUBLE TAKE.
>> THAT CLIP HAS BEEN PLAYED
MORE TIMES THAN BINGO AT THE
VILLAGES.
AND IT SHOULD, A POLITICIAN, TH
LOUDEST VOICES SAY TO FUND THE
POLICE WITHIN THEY DENY IT AND
LATER THEY ADMIT IT, THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT.
>> YOU CAN GET THAT OFF, I'M
GOING TO MAKE SURE I HAVE
SECURITY BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE
HAD ATTEMPTS ON MY LIFE AND I
HAVE TOO MUCH WORK TO DO, THERE
ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE THAT NEED
HELP RIGHT NOW FOR ME TO ALLOW
THAT SO IF I END UP SPENDING
200,000, IF I SPEND TEN MORE
DOLLARS ON IT, YOU KNOW WHAT, I
GET TO BE HERE TO DO THE WORK,
SO SUCK IT UP AND DEFUNDING THE
POLICE HAS TO HAPPEN.
WE NEED TO DEFUND THE POLICE AN
PUT THAT INTO A SOCIAL SAFETY
NET.
>> AND KNOW HER SLOGAN FOR THE
REELECTION CAMPAIGN, SUCK IT UP.
REALLY, YOU EXPECT ME TO BELIEV
PEOPLE VOTED FOR HER, IN MAJOR
CITIES ALL OVER LIFE IS CHANGIN
FOR THE WORSE, IT'S INCREMENTAL
BUT AN ACTIONABLE.
I THINK ABOUT THIS A LOT, WHEN
I'M NOT FANTASIZING ABOUT STUAR
BERNIE.
I THINK I FIGURED IT OUT, IT'S
PERFECT STORM OF DISTRACTION AN
EXPLOITATION, WE ARE DISTRACTED
EVERYTHING WE NEED AN ABUNDANCE
OF FOOD, NEWS, CAT VIDEOS,
INSTAGRAM AND TIK TOK KEEP THE
KIDS ENTHRALLED.
KEEPS THE BOYS GLUED TO THE
SCREENS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
STOPGAP, AND THEY CANCEL CULTUR
DECIDES WHETHER WE LIVE OR DIE,
WE ARE THE LUCKIEST GENERATION
OF SPOILED BRATS IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD BUT BECAUSE OF THA
WE STOPPED MINDING THE STORE AN
IN WALKED THE WORST OF THE WORST
.
THE RADICALS WHO SAID TO
THEMSELVES WHILE THESE SUCKERS
ARE NOSE DEEP IN THEIR PHONES,
WE CAN DO THIS.
NOW THERE AND EVERY POWER CENTER
, THEY'RE THE PROFESSORS,
JUDGES, SOCIAL MEDIA HONCHOS
EVEN KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS FOR
IT I GOT TO LI
>> HAPPY FRIDAY, EVERYONE.
IS SO SWEET, YOU CAN GET A
CAVITY IN YOUR EYEBALL JUST BY
LOOKING AT HER.
EMILY COMPANION NO.
SHE KNOWS FINANCING LIKE I KNOW
DANCING.
WRITER AND COMEDIAN AND, HE IS
LIKE A PLASTIC FORK, SHARP AND
SNAPS AND IS SOMETIMES SPOTTED
LAYING ON THE STREET.
THAT WAS THE MOST UPBEAT
MONOLOGUE I'VE EVER WRITTEN,
EMILY.
>> HAPPY FRIDAY.
>> HAPPY HOUR HAS BEGUN.
I HAVE A QUESTION I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THIS IF IT GOES
REALLY BAD AND THE WORLD SPLITS
BETWEEN WARDS OF FIENDS AND
MARAUDERS, AND GOOD PEOPLE
TRYING TO SURVIVE, WHICH SIDE
WOULD YOU BEYOND?
TO GIVE THE GOOD ONES FOR SURE.
>> WHY NOT JUST JOIN THE BAD
GUYS AND THEN YOU'LL BE SAFE,
EMILY?
>> BECAUSE MORE DAYS LIVING IN
HELL IS NOT WORTH ONE DAY OF
LIVING FREELY AND HAPPILY.
AND I FEEL LIKE WE ARE SEEING
THAT PLAY OUT IN THE CITY OF
PORTLAND.
THEY ARE SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ARE NOW PAYING FOR ARMED
SECURITY AND FOR BULLETPROOF
VESTS.
THIS IS ON TOP OF ALL THEIR LOS
REVENUE DURING COVID ON TOP OF
THEIR COST WITH COVID COMPLIANC
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND
PROTECTION IN ALL THAT STUFF AN
THIS ASTRONOMICAL WEST COAST
TAXES, AND NOW THEIR LIVELIHOOD
HAVE BEEN BURNED DOWN IN A 100
DAY PLUS RIOT THERE PREVENTED
FROM OPERATING THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF SMEARED ON
THE WALL.
MY FRIEND WHO EARNS A BAR THERE
GOT INTO A FIGHT WITH A BUM THA
WAS WIELDING A MACHETE, HE IS
THERE ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS THE REALITY THAT IS
FACING THE SMALL'S AND ITS
OWNERS.
>> YOU KNOW WHY HE'S MAD, THEY
CALL HIM GINGER BECAUSE HE IS
HAS RED HAIR.
THE POINT IS THE GOVERNMENT IS
BREAKING ITS DUTY, IT'S NOT
PROTECTING ITS CITIZENS ANYMORE
IT'S NOT PROSECUTING CRIMES,
THERE'S NO PENALTY FOR ANY OF
THESE VIOLENT CRIMES.
THEY ARE NOT PREVENTING OTHER
FROM INFRINGING UPON YOUR RIGHT
TO WHY SHOULD WE PAY THE
SALARIES OF THESE GUYS
ADVOCATING THEIR DUTIES THAT AR
INCOMPETENT BECAUSE CLEARLY
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO GET
ELECTED OVER AND OVER BY THE
LEFT, SO I THINK WE SHOULD ALL
STOP PAYING TAXES VERY THAT'S M
IDEA, I'LL SEE YOU IN JAIL.
>> A TRUE REVOLUTIONARY.
COMING IT'S NOT AS GOOD AS IT
SOUNDS.
>> IT SOUNDS CUTE LIKE LITTLE
MICE.
>> YOU SEE THAT HERE IN NEW YORK
, THE LOVE I HAVE HER PEN
STATION TO GET TO THE SUBWAY.
YOU HAVE TO WALK IN PEN STATION?
>> NO, THE WALKING DEAD IS BAD,
THE LIVING IS NO PLEASURE EITHER
.
IT'S JUST SO HORRIFYING WHAT HA
HAPPENED AND NONE OF IT IS
SURPRISING WHEN YOU LOOK BACK
WE'VE GOTTEN TO THIS MODE WHERE
IT'S PUNISHING PEOPLE WHO ARE
PRODUCTIVE AND REWARDING PEOPLE
WHO REFUSE TO CONTRIBUTE.
WHEN YOU GET TO THE HOMELESS
ISSUES, THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO AR
MENTALLY ILL, DRUG ADDICTS, YOU
NEED TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE.
TO GIVE THE OTHERS ARE JUST
SPONGING A.
THEY ARE UNDER 30.
I KNOW THEM.
THEY'RE ON MY BLOCK.
>> THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED.
>> I HAVE OFFERED THEM FOOD AND
THEY GET FUSSY.
THEY HAVE REQUIREMENTS.
IS THAT FREE RANGE?
I AM FREE RANGE, MY FOOD HAS TO
BE FREE RANGE.
>> IT'S VERY DEPRESSING WHEN YO
LOOK AT THAT BURGER PLACE I OKA
THEY MARKET IT IS FLAME BROILED
ON THE BURNING FEDERAL BUILDING
NEXT BIRKHEAD.
>> THEY NEED TO REBRAND SAY COM
HERE, TAKE A DUMP IN THE PARKIN
LOT.
>> THAT'S WHY YOU'RE NOT IN
MARKETING.
>> PEOPLE WHO NO LONGER ASK IF
YOU CAN USE THE RESTROOM, THEY
JUST ASSUME THEY CAN USE THE
DINING AREA OR THE PARKING LOTS.
>> HEATHER, YOU ARE AN OPTIMIST.
I MADE YOU REALLY SET IN THE
GREEN ROOM, I WAS CRYING.
>> IT'S TOUGH TO BE AN OPTIMIST
GIVEN THE MONOLOGUE, BUT I THIN
THE EMPATHETIC ARGUMENT SHOULD
NOT BE INCREASE THE WELFARE
STATE AND YOU BRING UP A GOOD
POINT THAT SOME OF THE HOMELESS
DO NEED HELP, BUT IN GENERAL, I
YOU LOOK AT THE JULY JOBS REPOR
THIS MORNING, IT WAS GREAT,
954,000 JOBS ADDED, THE AND
EMPLOYMENT RATE DOWN TO 9.4
PERCENT.
THE EMPATHETIC ARGUMENT IS
ACTUALLY GIVING THE HOMELESS AT
JOB AND GETTING THEM EDUCATION
AND SKILLS TRAINING, IT'S NOT
JUST CONTINUOUSLY GIVE THE MONE
DENVER PAYS ON AVERAGE, MORE
THEY SPENT ON HOMELESS AND THEY
DO ON K-12 EDUCATION AND ON
AVERAGE FOR HOMELESS PERSON,
THEY ARE MAKING ABOUT THE SAME
AS THE MEDIAN PERSON'S INCOME
THAT LIVES IN DENVER.
WHY WOULD YOU WORK?
>> I AM MOVING TO DENVER.
I LOVE THEIR OMELETTES.
CAT, I SEE AMERICA AS LIKE A
SEMITRUCK THAT WENT DOWN A BLIN
ALLEY, SO YOU CAN'T TURN AROUND
YOU CAN ONLY GO IN REVERSE.
>> I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT DRIVING
A SEMI SEMITRUCK, OR DRIVING.
I THINK THE PROBLEM IS IT'S A
BIT FAR GONE AT THIS POINT, I
MEAN THE CITY WAS ALREADY
LITERALLY ON FIRE AND THE MAYOR
TOOK THE SIDE OF THE PEOPLE
SETTING IT ON FIRE, AND THEN
EVERYONE IS SHOCKED THAT IT
KEEPS GETTING WORSE.
I THINK THAT OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED
TO FIRST OF ALL ACKNOWLEDGE
REALITY, THAT WOULD BE STEP ONE
STEP ONE IS ACKNOWLEDGING
REALITY AND SAYING THIS ISN'T
WORKING.
THIS ISN'T WORKING, THIS ISN'T
PROBLEM SOCIAL WORKERS CAN SOLVE
, AND I SAY THAT AS THE
DAUGHTER OF THE SOCIAL WORKER.
SHE'S DEAD NOW, BUT BUT COMMIT
YOU NEED LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OR PEOPLE AREN'T GOING TO FOLLO
THE LAWS.
>> YOU POINTED OUT TO CORY BUSH
IN THE OPENING MONOLOGUE AND SH
SAYS SHE WANTS TO HIRE HER OWN
PRIVATE SECURITY BECAUSE SHE'S
THE VICTIM OF CRIME.
I SAID WHO DO YOU THINK
INVESTIGATES IF A FEW OF THE
VICTIM OF THE CRIME, A
PSYCHOLOGIST, A SOCIAL WORKER?
WHO ARE YOU GOING TO CALL?
WAS I WRONG TO SUIT SO THE LAST
SCENE OF THE TICKET THAT FINALL
SHOWED UP IN MY NETFLIX QUEUE
AFTER 50 YEARS SPREAD.
>> PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW THE
ENDING OF THE PLANET OF THE APE
NOW.
I DON'T NEED TO SAY SPOILER
ALERT FOR IT.
>> EVEN THE APES ARE TRYING TO
LEAVE THE PLANET NOW GRAD